now we're joined by the women's rights
activist Patsy Stevenson
um thank you very much for being on the
program I'm really glad to have you in
this morning I feel like your face is
very familiar to me because I really
remember those images of you at the
Sarah everard protest I think we can see
um you know pinned The Ground by police
I was during covert times that's why
we've got the face mask on
I mean I don't want to go over you know
what happened there but just talk about
why you went on that protest and whether
you think anything's changed since then
well I mean number one it was a vigil
and I you know that's true I shouldn't
say yeah no but I mean people do
um you know and before that I was never
an activist I was never a protester
nothing like that I'd never really been
to a protest
um and now I go to protest all the time
um I'm in and out of parliament I'm
trying to get rid of bills that are
affecting us you know I'm constantly in
this world now and it's it's strange
that was two years ago and since then
we've not seen any change and this is
it's a it's a massive problem
um where we've got people at the top and
people in the Met police especially
where things happen and then when the
news dies down then promises are they're
empty promises and nothing happens so
you know I don't know what it's going to
take for actual change to happen but
sooner rather than later you know we're
losing people this is this is a real
epidemic you know
epidemic is a word isn't it really is
um part of the reason I wanted to get
you on is because I've just been reading
more and more about the awful murder of
Emma Patterson and her daughter
seven-year-old Epson College head
teacher killed alongside her daughter
her husband George also found dead but
of course the police believe that he
shot them and then killed himself and
you know I just feel like there's been a
lot of talk about a tragedy about a
murder suicide but it's a murder isn't
it that we're talking about here yeah
and again the problem is you know we've
got a lot of people reporting on it who
not only do people uh people often
speculate which is uh really damaging
um of its own but the headlines you can
find
the onus is always put on women and it's
ridiculous and the thing is that when
you when you post about this stuff I
post about it on Twitter and people are
like I don't see the misogyny if you
don't see the misogyny in this reporting
you might have internalized misogyny
yourself one headline did living in the
shadow of his high achieving wife lead
to Unthinkable tragedy I mean yeah again
I mean it's there's no excuse to murder
someone and it is it's again
fear-mongering young women into
believing that not only do they have all
of these other things to worry about men
killing them for if you achieve too much
you may be murdered by your own partner
that's ridiculous now sorry police
originally described it as an isolated
incident now of course you know I know
why they use those words as to reassure
people that there isn't a killer at
large
um but it's not an isolated is it a
woman occur by their Partners all the
time yeah and that's the problem
um I know a lot of women's rights
activists a lot of people that are
speaking up about this stuff a lot of
journalists like yourself that are
talking about this and trying to bring
it to to the public attention and say
listen we have a real issue here where
women are not being taken seriously this
is a real problem that is happening
every single day like you said every 30
seconds they're getting a call you know
and that's that's it's too much it's so
I mean one is too much but this is
ridiculous what kind of world are our
young girls coming into you know um and
I just wish that men would think hang on
this is really happening believe women
and just listen to the women in your
life who are telling you this is really
happening and and try and figure out how
you can help this you know you of course
um we know about you because what
happened and the way that you were dealt
with by the police at as you say a
peaceful vigil it's important to say
um we've seen recently of course David
Carrick of the Met police jailed for
life of 85 offenses including rapes and
sexual assaults How concerned are you
about the state of amapolu I mean it's I
was concerned like two years ago and
even then people were concern decades
before that about the Met police people
have always been saying this about the
police the the police system in general
needs a complete overhaul because it's
systemic it's really hiring women in the
police force isn't going to do it there
were women officers at the vigil they
know better than the Met it doesn't make
you
um you know a better police officer
that's not going to make you not sexist
you can have internalized misogyny
um and yeah so I mean the from what I've
seen of the police
these are just the things that have been
reported on we've got over a thousand
police officers being investigated at
the moment you know Mark Rowley said
that's two or three a week at the moment
and these people their job is to protect
and serve and they're actively abusing
the public when does it change do you
think that it's changing with the new
commissioner Mark Riley who does seem to
be doing quite a lot on this you know
he's he's giving evidence he's talking
about it he's saying that there's going
to be prosecutions the one thing I will
say about Mark Crowley is I think a lot
of people and I'm not talking for
everyone because I know people say that
this isn't true for them but I
appreciate the fact that he's admitting
and holding themselves accountable
however I don't think he is as serious
about it as he should be because we need
change right now and I think the change
that he's
saying will happen is not good enough in
my opinion you're talking a bit about
your own experience with the police what
was it like you know that night
I mean I can't talk much about it
because I'm possibly taking them to
court
um but it's you know for me I
I thought you could never be arrested
unless you do something wrong and that
is not the case that is not the case and
police are known to go to certain
communities and areas where
um you know if they arrest people for no
reason and it sounds far-fetched it's
like why would you arrest someone for no
reason it happens this is a truth
um and they go to these areas because
they can't take legal action against the
police to qualify for legal aid you need
to be earning nothing I didn't qualify
for legal aid and I was a student
earning nothing
um so it's you know there's not enough
help out there for people who are
unlawfully arrested
um and I think the police get a get away
with a lot of things because they're so
close to justices but you're now
considering legal action then is there
anything you can tell us about that or
yeah I mean so I started legal
proceedings
um last year I think it was
um I'm trying to raise 230
000 pounds by March I'm at 17 grand it's
probably not going to happen I'm I'm
hoping
um you know that that we can raise the
money just to take them to court or just
to pursue legal action
um you know I mean if Mark growley or
the police if they if they're doing what
they say they are
I I mean I'm waiting for a response you
know so it's I and it's not just for me
it's for every woman that attended that
vigil I saw what happened they saw what
happened
and the reporting on it you know there
were a lot of people that were reporting
on it and a lot of people did
did show what really happened but the
police got out first and said their side
of the story
and I can tell you now a lot of that
wasn't true
okay thank you very much for being on
the program today it's been great to
have you I've been really looking
forward to speaking thank you thank you